Hello ! Donc
une autre vidéo aujourd'hui que je
voulais parler d'une d'une aventure que
j'ai faite il y a de peut-être 2 ans
qui était
Vipassana. Je sais pas s'il y en a qui
savent c'est quoi. Moi personnellement
je connaissais pas. Je l'ai connu dans
une vidéo justement euh une vidéo
YouTube de quelqu'un comme comme moi
mettons aujourd'hui qui vous montre qui
vous explique euh passana puis ça m'a
intrigué puis là je me disais ben si
quelqu'un a fait cette vidéo là pu ça
m'a donné le goût de le faire ben je me
sentais euh je sentais que ben si
quelqu'un me l' fait pour moi ben je
vais la refaire pour quelqu'un d'autre
puis écoute on sait pas peut-être bien
qu'il vair quelun qui va écouter la
vidéo va peut-être
Ça pas être nice de l'essayer au moins.
Euh, il y en a trouvé ça bizarre, c'est
sûr ou vraiment trop intense. Euh, donc
euh sans plus tarder, on va commencer
directement. Donc c'est quoi euh ben
juste avant Ouais. Donc c'est quoi
personnel ? Le personnel en gros là
c'est euh il y en a partout dans le
monde, c'est des cours de méditation.
Personn c'est un type de méditation,
c'est une technique de méditation que tu
apprends dans le fond dans ce cours là.
C'est des cours de 10 jours. Tu peux pas
commencer sans faire le cours de 10
jours qui est le le le strict minimum.
Cours de 10 jours qui est tu me dis 10h
par jour. Donc méditer euh
dans une salle, tu médites donc 10h par
jour, donc ça donne 100 he à la fin des
10 jours. Donc c'est pour ça que c'est
vraiment intense. Il y a beaucoup de
gens qui vont quitter puis tout le monde
dedans va penser à quitter euh
plusieurs fois pendant le séjour. Euh
mais faut vraiment pas t'arrêter à ça.
C'est euh justement c'est un travail
mental énorme puis de l'apprentissage
énorme. Donc euh
d' it fait qu'on va commencer
directement. Donc euh c'est quoi genre
pourquoi euh 10h de méditation par jour
puis pourquoi 100 he de méditation jour
puis pourquoi c'est intense de même.
Donc c'est quoi dans fond ? Ben moi, je
l'ai fait d'abord. Je l'ai fait il y a 2
ans à un centre de un centre de Passana
qui est à Montebello donc entre Montréal
et Ottawa
et donc un super beau centre dans le
fond
quand tu arrives là-bas, il y a pas
grand monde qui sait à quoi s'attendre
quand je veux dire tu connais personne
qui l' fait, tu sais pas trop à quoi
t'attendre puis tout. C'est vraiment une
belle ambiance, c'est nice, cool. Euh,
je veux dire, il y a le monde sont pas
weird là. C'est vraiment juste des
humains bien normals puis qui veulent
juste être heureux.
Euh, comment ça se passe ? Tu te lèves à
4h du matin, à tous les matins, tu te
lèves à 4h du matin, tu vas méditer, tu
vas avoir trois repas puis tu vas te
coucher à comme 9h30,
9h30 environ. Puis te faire commencer ça
pendant 10 jours. Euh comment que ça
s'est passé ?
Pour moi, ben ça d'abord, il faut savoir
que c'est sans téléphone, sans aucune
distraction, même que les gars et les
filles sont divisé, sont pas dans les
mêmes salles, sont pas dans les mêmes.
On on voit, il y a comme en tout cas,
c'est divisé en deux pendant divisant
pour les deux sexes sont divisés, on se
voit pas, on se cout pas. C'est vraiment
pour éliminer au maximum toutes les les
distractions que tu pourrais avoir pour
être pleinement euh présent pour ta
méditation.
Euh c'est ça. Donc tu parles pas aussi
sans conversation, sans musique. Tu peux
même pas euh échanger un regard avec
quelqu'un. Donc c'est vraiment en mode
axé 100 % sur toi-même, sur ton ressenti
à l'intérieur de toi. Euh c'est un
travail qui est hyper exigeant.
Euh
non, c'est ça. Au final, Fana,
l'objectif c'est de voir à quel point
c'est bruyant dans ta tête. C'est c'est
bruyant dans ta tête comment ça bouge
énormément dans ta tête. C'est ça
l'objectif de V passana. Ben, c'est pas
juste ça, mais dans le sens que tu te
rends compte de ça. Tu te rends compte
que dans ta tête là, ça bouge
énormément. puis tu as énormément de
pensées qui bougent euh qui arrivent
puis c'est de savoir que tu es pas
emprisonné avec. Tu peux travailler avec
pour être en contrôle puis de contrôler
tes pensées dans ta tête
puis que ça dans le monde des affaires,
c'est un super pouvoir de pouvoir
contrôler ta tête.
dans la vie de tous les jours de tout le
monde, il y a tellement de gens qui sont
stressés par plein de choses qui vont se
laisser emporter par plein d'affaires
puis que même la moindre petite affaire
dans leur vie qui fait pas leur affaire,
ça va les stresser puis ils vont juste
penser à ça pu ça fait qu'ils vont pas
pouvoir prendre des risques dans leur
vie qui sont plus grands que la norme
parce qu'ils vont tout le temps être
dans leur tête puis ça c'est vraiment
euh c'est triste au final et fa j'é
Justement, c'est un outil qui te permet
de travailler ton esprit pour être
capable par la suite de mieux vivre avec
le risque. Donc moi, c'est comme ça je
l'ai vécu.
Ça te permet vraiment là de te
concentrer dans le moment présent,
d'être capable d'observer ton corps.
Donc ça c'est vraiment ça c'est la
technique de passana. La technique
deana, c'est tu scanes ton corps
corporel,
les sensations corporelles que tu as en
bas, puis tu vas les observer sans les
juger d'être écoanime. C'est ça le le
mot principal de person, c'est être
équan de observer sans jugement parce
que dans ta vie, tu es tout le temps en
train de juger les choses sans le
vouloir. inconscient, mais soit tu vas
vivre de du désir, donc d'en vouloir
plus,
d'en vouloir de tout le temps être en
manque et en aversion. Donc euh la peur
ou le fait de manquer ça, non, ça marche
pas. Non. Euh la version, comment je
pourrais le décrire ? Juste le fait de
ne pas vouloir quelque chose. Ouais, on
pourrait dire ça comme ça. Le fait de
c'est le contraire du désir. C'est tu
veux tu t'es fait mal dernière fois, tu
as mal dans le dos, ben quand tu vas
commencer à avoir mal dans le dos, ben
tu vas changer de position parce que tu
associes le mal de ton dos à quelque
chose de négatif
puis tu juges. Au final, l'objectif
c'est de vraiment devenir équanime et
juste d'observer
tes sensations.
Parce que tes sensations, pourquoi les
sensations que tu observes, c'est
pourquoi tu observes tes sensations ?
C'est qu'au final tes sensations, c'est
euh comment qu' l'explique ? C'est euh
la partie de ton de ta conscience qui
est le plus profond. Donc là, on a pu ce
technique là, mais euh c'est ça, c'est à
partie de la qui nécessite une
conscience la plus profonde pour être
capable de sentir toutes tes sensations,
toutes tes sensations dans ton corps.
En tout cas, c'est pas le plus important
pour aujourd'hui là, mais au final, le
fait de être équanime, de t'entraîner
l'esprit à être équanime, de pas juger,
mais c'est justement ça te permet de
dans ta vie d'entrepreneur de pouvoir
prendre des risques qui sont plus gros
puis de ne pas être en train de juger en
mode désir de e je veux gagner de
l'argent, je veux que ça soit, je veux
que ça marche, je va avoir plus
d'employés, je vais avoir plus de
clients, je vais avoir tu sais tout le
temps être dans ce désir là de tout un
manque
C'est quand tu es toujours en désir, ben
tu es pas heureux au final. Tu es pas
dans le moment présent, tu es pas en
C'est ça. Tu es tu es pas heureux au
final,
tu es tout le temps dans le désert. Il
te manque quelque chose tout le temps.
Même chose pour la version. He euh il me
manque
je sais pas moi euh
il a il il a pas payé ses factures euh
telle personne a pas payé ses factures.
On va ça va pas bien non et là il faut
pas que là on tombe dans le négatif tout
ça puis tu tombe dans justement la
version de tu juges ça full négativement
fait que tu passes encore ta journée à
être dans le négatif négatif négatif
fait dans tous les cas même que tu sois
dans le désir ou que tu sois dans
l'agression tu es dans le négatif parce
que tu es pas en train de vivre le
moment présent puis de accepter la
situation telle qu'elle est
c'est ça l'entraînement de l'esprit
deana accepter sa vie tel qu'elle est.
Euh
donc là, je m'étais mis quelques points
mais je pense que
je vais directement plonger sur ce que
je voulais en venir. Donc juste
prochaine fois tu vis quelque chose dans
ta vie qui est difficile, soit que tu
vis du désir justement que tu es en
manque, je sais pas argent, temps,
je sais pas moi, peu importe.
Prends un moment,
arrête-toi, reste pas, fais je dire
d'observer ce que ce que tu sens en
dedans de toi. Même chose pour ton
stress. Tu vis du stress à ta job, tu
vis du stress à ta business, peu
importe, ça se passe pas comme tu
voulais. Prends un moment, respire
puis juste observe. Observe ton corps.
Des fois, c'est peut-être plus difficile
mais juste
observe ton corps. Comment tu te sens ?
Est-ce que tuas une pression dans ton
dans ton chest qui est comme moi c'est
souvent ça m quand je parle je parle
pour moi mett du stress ça va être genre
une pression au niveau du du chest puis
ok tu sens que c'est il y a une pression
là puis juge pas cette pression là juge
pas ça juste tu l'observes puis de la
manière de l'observer tu vas te
dissocier de cette pression là dans ton
corps. Je sais pas si c'est clair, je
sais pas si c'est comme trop intense
pour du monde, on faire what the fuck ?
Mais juste observer, au lieu de être ce
stress là, tu observes le stress
pu ça te permet de te dissocier du
stress puis de pouvoir justement faire
des choses pas plus big dans ta vie
parce que tu n'es pas ce stress là. tu
es juste quelqu'un qui va faire des
projets d'ampillion tout ça puis qui va
vivre les défis, qui va les surmonter,
qui va apprendre puis qui va au final
vivre sa vie puis réaliser plein de
grandes choses. mais de pas être ce
stress là, ne pas être ne pas s'associer
à ce mal-être là qui soit relié à du
désir ou de l'aversion, mais qui est
juste en mode
je suis heureux de ma vie que je vis,
j'accepte ce qui se passe dans ma vie en
ce moment même.
Je pense que comme ça toutes les gens
seraient beaucoup plus heureux, beaucoup
plus en paix avec leur vie. Donc
that's Salut